alors lendemain d'un débat michel david
emmanuelle latraverse vincent marissal
chantal hébert merci d'être là gros
panel on a bien sûr hâte de vous
entendre
bonsoir à tous messieurs dames mais
avant de parler de débat si vous le
voulez bien nouvelle aujourd'hui
monsieur harper canon ce qu'il voit
comme david cameron l'avait promis en
grande bretagne quelques semaines qui va
inscrire dans une loi
l'impossibilité pour lui d'augmenter les
taxes et impôts n'écoutions vient toute
une c'est clair que les autres partis
fassent reprise des hausses de taxes
d'impôts et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils s'opposent à une telle
législation
mais c'est notre garantie depuis 2006 le
parti conservateur
nos os par des taux des taxes et des
impôts et des taxes et des impôts
fédéraux
ce n'est pas notre intention c'est clair
dans notre plan et c'est notre garantie
bon on le disait un peu plus tôt dans
l'émission avec denis ferland il ya
quelque chose de éminemment symbolique
chantal hébert mais on veut souligner
encore plus si c'était possible le fait
qu'il ne veut pas toucher aux taxes et
aux impôts
exact c'est une idée qui vient de la
grande bretagne de vous étonner de
savoir que monsieur harper est allé se
recruter un génie de la stratégie
australien qui a fait ses armes restent
en grande bretagne mais d'autre part
moi j'y vois un petit peu plus que ça
vous savez au cours de la semaine on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé mais les deux
principaux partis d'opposition ont
déclaré de façon catégorique qu'ils
appuieraient jamais le discours du trône
d'un gouvernement conservateur après du
9 octobre un autre monde gouvernement
monsieur harper s'y est minoritaire et
menacé pas duré très longtemps et moi je
crois que monsieur harper se prépare à
remplir ce discours du trône si jamais
il gagne et qui est minoritaire avec des
mesures qui vont lui permettre de dire
regardez ce à quoi les
libéraux et les néo démocrates disent
non et regarder ce qui se prépare à
faire avec un oeil sur une autre
élection je veux pas vous décourager le
la mède des boss est vrai que c'est un
peu dur passé tout ça vincent marissal
bon c'est la stratégie mais ça ça peut
marquer l'imaginaire ou à monedan
symbolique je suis d'accord avec chantal
ça pourrait faire office de pilule
empoisonnée parce que je suis persuadé
que si monsieur harper est minoritaire
il y aura pas l'intention de s'éterniser
très très très longtemps puis essayer de
trouver des alliances dans notre chambre
des communes avec les autres pensent
qu'il va il faut jouer le tout pour le
tout très très rapidement sedan ça passe
ou ça casse
alors la pilule empoisonnée en a une qui
est parfaite parce qu'évidemment les
partis d'opposition si tenté que ce sont
le npd les libéraux voteront jamais pour
un truc pareil et puis ça peut se
réalise en même temps parce qu'on a
l'impression que monsieur harper s'il
est élu veut s'attacher les mails
lui-même pour pas aussi les impôts est
ce à dire que monsieur à peu croit pas
ses propres promesses
alors on voit bien qu'on est dans le
symbole ici et si le site courant dont
on ne parle de la grande bretagne aux
états unis
le tea party qui était pour ce genre de
mesures michel emmanuel donc c'est à
dire mais moi je m'attache sur le mode
du bateau là je mange ma boucherie
d'agir la vie chère oui mais aussi pour
évidemment monsieur harper ne promet pas
d'augmentation texte mais il pourra
toujours dire si au moment de présenter
un budget s'il faut négocier avec les
autres et que les autres disent écoutez
là comme condition pour vous appuyer il
faudrait augmenter si vse trudeau
pourrait avoir des exigences à monsieur
marquer aussi
et monsieur après pourra leur dire
écoutez je voudrais bien mais je peux
pas d'argent projet de loi qui doit être
adoptée par la chambre et ou qui a été
adopté
et qui ne peux pas me permettre
d'augmenter les impôts alors d'une
manière ou d'une autre je n'ai pas un
show invaincu de la vie de vincent sait
que je pense pas que ça ils ont le
suspense ou l'obstacle dur tellement
tellement longtemps mais c'est des
petits outils chantal en a fait
référence et m'a laissé les petits
joue-t-il on sent là le marketing
politique très clairement oui c'est un
outil de marketing paul ou pôles
politiques pour faire une
différenciation très clair avec ses
adversaires mais vous disiez plutôt que
monsieur un peu sa tâche après le mode
du bateau mais d'une certaine façon ils
essaient d'attacher ses adversaires
aussi à part sur mes autres moi si vous
me passez l'expression c'est comme s'ils
mettaient en place tous les éléments
pour empêcher que s'ils étaient
minoritaires que ça puisse fonctionner
donc il donne les outils pour empêcher
ses adversaires de l'appuyer et se donne
lui même les outils pour s'empêcher de
faire des compromis avec ses adversaires
une partie d'échecs la dent et des
signaux et des six autres classes bon
très bien pour ça je le disais lendemain
de débats première question sur les
soins de la santé qui n'a pas été
entendu
je fais de l'ironie évidemment qui n'a
pas été entendu par les chefs de partis
ils ont parlé d'autre chose deuxième
question sur le droit à mourir qui n'a
pas levé beaucoup beaucoup non plus
quoique on a eu quelques précisions et
là je fais écouter un extrait c'était la
troisième question du débat sur le
fameux débat sur le niqab on écoute un
court extrait convient limoges bagages
le premier projet qui sera déposée par
le bloc québécois
je serai prête leur interdire qui est
vote à visage découvert assermentation m
avoir donné des services publics à 10
heures
c'est un homme
on ne peut pas imposer sa volonté de
pour elle
comment une femme savait on devrait pas
avoir un état qui impose comment une
femme devrait pas s'allier je ne vais
jamais dire la jeune fille qu'une femme
devrait se couvrir le visage parce
qu'elle est monsieur pour vous attaquez
vous à l'opération si vous croyez qu'il
ya oppression nada et le courage de
faire ça mais c'est pas en privant ces
femmes de la citoyenneté et de leurs
droits que vous allez réussir à les
aider bon alors le débat s'est enflammé
c'était donc c'était une évidence
remarquer d'un côté les studios et
mulcair de l'autre sur un peu et
monsieur duceppe
qu'avez vous pensé de ce débat quant à
moi j'ai l'impression j'ai eu
l'impression que le plan de marche de
stephen harper au débat cet ex il y
avait une seule chose que les électeurs
qui le regardait aller se rappeler ce
serait sa position sur le niqab
il en a même reparlé à la fin dans son
petit moule clôture et je pense que les
conservateurs et on commence à le voir
dans les sondages publics voient dans le
relevé de sondages que pour une fois ils
ont trouvé un thème qui porte au québec
ce qui est ce qui était rare pour eux et
d'autre part le premier référence je
n'ai pas nécessairement dans l'yonne
c'est de faire que des gens qui
pensaient à voter conservateur mais qui
était discret pour être poli se sent
moins discret sortent un peu du
garde-robe poudrier moi je vote
conservateur et voici pourquoi
parce que c'est un sujet qui porte ici
vesa il n'y a pas eu de révélation ils
ont répété leur position mais c'était un
résumé assez claire de ce débat
et puis les conservateurs monsieur
rappeur il vient pas au québec en
conquérant
leurs projets leurs projets
d'exploration au québec ces cinq six
sept sièges
il serait très très très content en
mesure à peu et il savait qu'avec le
niqab il pouvait titiller son électorat
ou un électorat peut-être dormant le des
cellules dormantes conservatrice qui se
réveille avec ça et qui rompt pas voter
bloc québécois à l'endroit ce sens le
fait que monsieur duceppe insiste
beaucoup beaucoup aussi là dessus j'ai
l'impression que quelque part il fait
beaucoup de passes sur la palette de
mesures accrues qui en ont profités moi
j'ai parlé avec des conservateurs
aujourd'hui des candidats il était
satisfait comme des chats qui venaient
de manger un canari je pense qu'ils
savent que ça sent bon dans certains
coins du québec pourrait penser par
exemple la région de québec et quelques
autres ailleurs monsieur harper il s'est
tenue très loin volontairement de tous
les aspects juridiques là il est allé
sur le symbole il a même parlé de sa
fille alors ils savaient qu'ils
voulaient pas dans son col ça fait deux
fois nous a parlé de son fils ou s'il a
quand il a vu la mairie taux d'exode
thiriez n'a malheureusement qui était
décédé sur une plage de grèce
michel pour gilles duceppe steve une des
premières grandes tribunes là où ils
pouvaient s'adresser à pas mal de
québécois en même temps là dessus bien
sûr il a la main posions écharpe mais
c'est son problème il risque de faire le
jeu demeure
monsieur mal qu'elle se débattait comme
un diable dans l'eau bénite le hier il
se rend bien compte et on voit y est
revenu là dessus à plusieurs reprises qu
il sent le tapis lui glisser en dessous
du pied et
il aurait pas de tout un côté le vrai
enjeu la spa le niqab c'est ben harper
et c'est moi je suis le premier surpris
de voir quand même que ce débat-là
semble avoir fait disparaître toutes les
raisons que les gens ont depuis des
années de vouloir se débarrasser de
stephen harper est maintenant
semble-t-il le niqab le niqab c'est
épouvantable et quand monsieur duceppe
envoie à marquer écoutez il avoue être
prêt à sacrifier les droits des femmes
pour acheter des votes à toronto sa
femme anne emmanuelle là dessus pour
conclure mais je voudrais que ce qui
était aussi remarquable il faut
mentionner
il ya dans ce débat sur le niqab c'est à
quel point sur l'enjeu sur laquelle
avait beaucoup misé monsieur trudeau la
semaine dernière et à quel point il est
il plus effacé dans ce débat-là moi ce
qui m'a frappé c'est même à l'époque du
débat sur la chair des valeurs ici au
québec qu'il n'y avait pas de testament
de votre directs en jeu pour lui mettait
le premier à sauter dans la mêlée à
sortir la chasse à se porter à la
défense du droit à des minorités
religieuses de porter leurs signes
religieux et caetera et aujourd'hui hier
on le veut un discours beaucoup plus
ténu de l'huile a tué ce que c'est sa
difficulté en français de sauter dans le
débat au bon moment où c'était
stratégique
ça reste à voir mais c'était aussi un
des éléments du débat qui était qui
était quand même de la semaine passée
pour le match mais aussi exactement jeu
il ya eu des débats sur le sénat débat
aussi sur l'économie on va faire une
courte pause dont poursuit cette analyse
dans deux minutes
non je ne suis promis de m'assurer que
le 19 octobre
j'ai cherché un monde avec les électeurs
du canada pour commencer le processus de
travailler avec les provinces pour nous
débarrasser enfin de cet endroit qui ne
sert qu'à mettre des anciens libéraux et
les anciens conservateur dans une
sinécure avec un élan que j'ai changé je
sais pas changé avons essayé et la seule
façon pour les québécois et les
québécoises de sortir de ce problème là
c'est de se donner pays monsieur duceppe
elle développe à ces dates souhaitées
par ces dates pour le canada c'est comme
si des tonnes déplacer les gens se parer
à ce débat qui compte dans lequel on
sombre va pas créer des emplois va pas
répondre à vos priorités à la maison on
veut investir
on va vous donner des baisses d'impôts
les gens s'embourbe dans des discussions
constitution de souveraineté d'identité
à la place on peut parler de comment on
va bâtir une économie plus forte
alors sur le débat sur le sénat c'est
très simple c'est un quatre contre eur /
mulcair continue à dire c'est possible
je pus l'abolir en parle en province
bien que ça prend l'unanimité des
provinces pour abolir le sénat donc
rendre conditionnel donc la question du
québec
donc la question des autochtones
également qu'avez vous pensé de ce débat
messieurs dames
chantal que monsieur marqueur semblait
plus confortable dans ce débat là que
dans plusieurs autres questions qu'il
était presque convaincant si on oublie
qu'il peut l'unanimité des provinces et
que c'est pas quelque chose qui est
offert il ya quand même dans le discours
de vérité d une absence pendant
longtemps jack layton et après ça
monsieur marqueur parler aussi du fait
que le québec reviendra latham et et
comptes rentrait de s'occuper de l'autre
ce jour qui a pas été complétée geipan
temps de soya non parce que tous les
autres ont fermé la porte
vincent encore là il ya deux choses il
ya la mécanique
et puis
il est le symbole monsieur michael est
encore là et pas les huîtres aux trolls
dans la mécanique les qu'il faudrait
reçoit les provinces la formule
d'amendements tout ça parce que ça
personne ne veut vraiment en entendent
parler depuis dans un débat c'est un peu
rébarbatif sauf que une telle chose
existe malgré tout fière je pense qu'il
en est plutôt tenu à cette chose inique
qui est le sénat cette institution
archaïque d'église ou dégoûtant le de
kératine
mais bon si chantal je suis tellement
content que vous ouvriez l'abord parce
qu'elle a l'impression que c'est ce qui
a fait le plus parler c'était de
l'humour parce que c'était prévu je dise
dégoûtant et quand on pratiquait les
questions ça dégoûte et une majorité
canadiens je vais le répéter puis je
voulais faire un clin d'oeil à mes
enfants dia ah c'est pas un google
bon enfin la parenthèse ce que j'ai dit
avant et je le répète je vous entends de
là dessus j'aurais aimé ne pas parler du
sénat peut-être dans un débat comme
celui là il ya des questions plus près
déjà mais avec l'année qu'on a connu et
est ce que monsieur mulcair
j'entendais michel là dessus et emmanuel
okon vaincu les canadiens que y allait
arriver elle l'abolir se signala non je
pense qu'il n'y a pas réussi à les
convaincre et un moment donné il y a
essayé je pense de leur faire croire que
ce serait pas si complique quand il a
dit écoute et là moi j'étais dans un
gouvernement
ou en fait j'étais pas dans un
gouvernement il était à l'assemblée
nationale mais l'assemblée nationale a
réussi à s'entendre pour modifier les
commissions scolaires a enfin passé des
commissions confessionnelles à des comme
si on est geek on a réussi à s'entendre
avec atom médias c'est pas du tout la
même chose ça prenait pas l'accord des
autres provinces
alors s'imaginer qu'on veut qu'on
pourrait faire l'économie d'un drame
constitutionnel en abolissant arrive
normal sénat c'est une vue de l'esprit
mais monsieur couillard qui a vraiment
pas envie de s'embarquer dans tout ça
c'est qu'il n'aurait pas le choix que de
mettre toutes les demandes du québec sur
la table et dieu sait ce qui en
sortirait et ça c'est l'élément patrice
du débat auquel monsieur monsieur mika
ne veulent pas y répondre
chantal il faisait référence tout comme
en année le québec à cette table de
négociations la question a déjà été
posée à monsieur couillard dans le cadre
de cette campagne des moissons par le
sénat on parle du reste ou six mois
quand j'étais à vue monsieur mulcair
la semaine dernière je vous ai carrément
la question et dit ah vous savez c'est
normal ce une game c'est un jeu
politique de la part de monsieur
couillard de dire ça et cetera mais
c'est quand même un peu l'éléphant dans
la pièce de sa stratégie pour l'abolir
le sénat et il ya peut-être réussi à
esquiver la question mais elle en est
pas moins présent dans ces des voleurs
très bien alors on veut penser de façon
plus générale il n'y a pas eu
je vous entends de chacun rapidement là
dessus je pense qu'on s'entend toujours
pas eu de grands gagnants de grands
perdants c'était une occasion
j'ouvre une parenthèse chantal au delà
du dégoûtant a eu huit cent mille
personnes parce que des gens ce matin
qui prétendaient qu'ils prétendaient que
ce débat-là après une demi heure allait
chuter à les chiffres montrent que huit
cent mille personnes à la télévision
parle pas du web la presse plus et tout
cela mais juste à la télé huit cent
mille personnes
du début jusqu'à la fin donc ces
annexions parti à d'autres sont entrés
les chiffres se sont maintenus donc un
intérêt didactique peut-être pas tout le
monde qui a suivi tous les bulletins de
nouvelles
bref est ce qu'il y ait eu un gagnant
perdant est ce qu'on en sort quand même
mieux
informé vincent je commence par vous jeu
pour persuader parce que par moment
évidemment la formule fait que ces
débats donc ça devient cacophonique et
puis surtout les échanges entre monsieur
mike hayes et monsieur après un moment
donné monsieur mac avait visiblement pas
du tout l'intention de laisser parler
monsieur monsieur après c'est peut-être
même un des passagers on aurait voulu
peut-être en savoir un peu plus le staff
évidemment sur sur le niqab
pour le reste donc plutôt répété leur
position les positions des gilles
duceppe sons sont très connus lorsqu'un
des chefs des chevals de monsieur
trudeau passe la soirée d'ailleurs un
petit peu coincé puis un peu effacée a
répété j'ai un plein je pense que c'est
très très convaincant pour les élèves
parce qu'un clan tout le monde peut en
avoir
il s'agit de savoir ce qu'il ya dedans
et monsieur trouvera de toute évidence
arrivait peau avec justement une ligne
précise pour convaincre je les cache ce
6e la dentelle dossier chantal moi je
pense que les électeurs trouvent
toujours quand même leur compte de voir
les cinq chefs dans ce que si en
présence et de se faire une tête en y
voyant de façon différente qu'à la
période des questions ou en train de
faire une annonce alors à ce niveau là
je suis pas convaincu que les positions
des uns et des autres sur à peu près
tous les sujets soient d'une importance
capitale que la majorité des électeurs
quand vous allez voter je pense pas que
vous amenez le programme électoral de
chaque partie
c'est vrai qu'il ya peut-être pas eu de
gagnant évident moi je pense et
j'attends de voir si des sondages donc
donné raison et ça se peut que ce soit
pas le cas je pense que stephen harper
est une bonne soirée
michel l'intérêt d'un débat comme celui
là où on a abordé beaucoup de questions
c'est que ça permet bruit d'informer le
public un peu mais surtout de voir
quelle est la performance générale des
chefs et de répondre à la question qui
est la plus fondamentale lequel ferait
le meilleur premier ministre est dans
cette optique là j'ai trouvé que
monsieur trudeau avait vraiment sous
performer quand on le regarde elle à
répondre à peu près la même chose avec
son plan économique a peu importe la
question même l'aide médicale à mourir
on se dit ce gars là est pas vraiment
mais monsieur harper a joué le premier
ministre sait que réserve je trouve que
si c'est pour ce qui est des objectifs
atteints c'est probablement lui qui a
atteint les siens mais se moquer avait
l'air d'un premier ministre il ya eu des
problèmes avec le nickel dit les
problèmes un peu aussi avec avec le
référendum mais il avalait premier
ministrable alors que monsieur trudeau
la lune en avait pas là monsieur duceppe
bon ben on sait qu'il ne sera pas là il
y avait une bonne performance mais enfin
cesser de moindres conséquences
emmanuel en conclusion ce qu'il ya des
pièces qui vous a frappé vous parce que
m'a frappé c'est d'un commun me suis dit
c'est pas réussi à tirer son épingle du
jeu dans ce dans ce débat-là en lançant
le défi à ses adversaires de prendre
position sur des enjeux à tout citoyen
peut réussir comme à renouveler une
partie de son discours dans le cadre de
cette campagne
donc oui efficace et la performance de
monsieur trudeau ou si vous savez nous
c'est vrai que ça fait serge ducas
puisque 55 jours que ça dure les lignes
on commence à les connaître mais pour
les 800000 personnes d'avoir écouté le
débat
ces gens là c'était l'occasion pour eux
de le voir monsieur codou de l'entendre
et il a été beaucoup moins efficace
beaucoup moins habiles convaincre qu'il
ne l'avait été dans d'autres débats
anglais très bien en terme d'atteinte
d'objectifs
oui il est définitivement passée sous la
barre haché pétrole à michel emmanuel
vincent chantal merci infiniment va se
retrouver au fil de cette campagne qui
est pas fini il reste trois semaines
trois grosses semaines de campagne
électorale
merci beaucoup en ce vendredi soir en
fin de semaine et à travers moi